[Music]
the sperm whale can click at about
236 decibels it's the loudest animal on
the planet sperm whales can hear each
other in the ocean from hundreds even
thousands of miles away some researchers
believe that they're able to keep in
contact with one another through these
clicks on other sides of the planet
these clicks are so powerful in the
water that they can blow out your
eardrums easily and they can actually
vibrate a human body to death
so when you're diving with them it's a
little sketchy
what i'm going to show you now is a
video of some free divers that i ended
up hanging out with i wasn't with them
during this expedition but uh i was
about six months later we went on trip
together and i had the same experience
so the clicks you're going to be hearing
are not coming from a boat they aren't
coming from a camera these are the
whales clicking these guys literally
from the inside out to see what they're
all about
and um the clicks were so powerful that
one of these guys put out his hand to
stop a whale from running into him and
his hand actually was paralyzed for
about four hours afterwards so he
learned not to keep out his hand in
front of him when he was diving this is
an emerging discipline of research and
it's pretty sketchy but um this is what
it's like i'm i'm not going to talk over
this uh
we're going to play this kind of loud so
you can really get an experience of what
this is all about
underneath
right now
okay so i know what you're thinking
why the hell would anyone want to do
that
i know that was pretty loud for all of
us but trust me in the water it's like
four million times louder and
uh once you're hanging out with the
whales for a long time this didn't
happen to me but it happened to these
guys their bodies started heating up
from being
pelleted with all of that energy after a
while um so
again uh this is pretty sketchy stuff
it's strange to do um
but it's important to note that these
guys are fascinated by whales they don't
necessarily want to free dive with them
this closely but they have to because it
turns out the only way to really study
these animals up close is by free diving
with them by approaching them in your
natural form and interacting with them
in that way scuba doesn't work it's too
loud submarines don't work same thing
robots don't work they freak them out
but when you free dive with them this
amazing paradigm shift occurs and they
not only don't swim away but most of the
time the whales will turn around and
welcome you into the pod sometimes they
orient themselves vertically and do this
very weird sort of new age thing around
you as they're as they're clicking it's
extremely intense so the next question
you're probably asking yourself is like
why research sperm whales well it turns
out that those clicks you heard
they aren't just used for echolocation
sperm whales and dolphins also use
clicks for communication and inside of
those clicks is probably one of the most
sophisticated forms of communication
we've discovered on the planet could be
more sophisticated than human language
now i know that sounds completely nuts
to all of you and it certainly sounded
nuts to me when i first started
researching the stuff a couple of years
ago but just consider a couple things
the sperm will brain
is about six times the size of ours
this is a picture of sperm whales facing
us head-on and that top thing is their
nose and behind that is their brain
now sperm whales also have a neocortex
in humans the neocortex is believed to
govern higher level functions like
conscious thought
future planning and language well sperms
not only have a neocortex but theirs is
about six times the size of ours
sperm whales also have spindle cells
these are long and highly developed
brain structures that neurologists have
associated with compassion
love
suffering and you guessed it speech all
of those things that make humans human
and separate us from great apes well
uh spermos not only have spindle cells
but have them in a far larger quantity
than we do and they've had them for 15
million years longer than we have
[Music]
you